and on behalf of Professor Matthew
Connell a professor in the Department of
History and director of the Hertog
global strategy initiative and myself
it's a pleasure to welcome you to
tonight's talk the Hertog global
strategy initiative is a research
program in the Department of History
that employs historical analysis to
confront present and future problems in
world politics we're very grateful for
the support of Roger Hertog after which
the program is named which made this
program possible
last year each year some subject of
importance in predicting the future and
understanding history for predicting the
future is addressed last year was
nuclear proliferation as you know this
year pandemics and indeed we have I
think a terrific speaker tonight for
that this program is also co-sponsored
by the Center for the history of F and
ethics of Public Health Group in
Columbia University's Mailman School of
Public Health's Department of
sociomedical Sciences and we have
delighted to have their participation as
well it's really a privilege for me to
be introducing professor Robert G
Webster who's one of the most
distinguished scientists of our time he
has illuminated many of the aspects of
the ecology and much of our
understanding of the ecology of
influenza really comes from professor
Webster's work he's the Rosemarie thomas
chair enviro ology at the st. Jude
Children's Research Hospital in addition
to being professor of biology and
molecular biology there he's also a
member of the National Academy of
Sciences and a fellow of the Royal
Society and without further ado it's my
pleasure to introduce dr. Webster who'll
talk about influenza lessons learned
from influenza pandemics and it's a
great honor to have
Thank You Steven it's my pleasure to be
here and so I'd like this to be filly
informal and so do interrupt because I
can dance around the field of influenza
from most every aspect so just to begin
this in fact I'll have the first one
back again the the side panel as Steven
knows as a stained glass window in my
home which is the natural history of flu
and shows the influence of iris going
from the the the wild duck to the pink
to human and the genetic mix-up and they
read for the fever and so on so that's
managed to get onto the cover of
emerging infectious diseases and several
other places next one and so I'm going
to move ten but others will take the
history way back to the time of the
Greeks and Helen of Troy and so on so
the the the the prehistory of flu really
extends a long way back and the things
that we do know from archaeological
studies on ceará is that there had been
outbreaks before 1918 of h2 and h3
subtypes probably h1 as well and really
a history of influenza starts in 1918
with the the Spanish flu pandemic
then with the h2 in 283 and 2 and more
recently when we were planning for the
next pandemic in thinking about h5n1
what did nature do to us they sent us
another h1n1 the scientists were all
caught with their pants down if you like
and and made no plans for an h1n1 it was
either going to be an h9 in to an h5n1
or in h2 n2 perhaps but not another h1
in one so this this is quite unheard of
and created a precedent and egg all over
our faces and so on so next one and so
this is the where we stood a short time
ago on the h1n1 pandemic of 2009 by
August the 10th WH o 2010 WH o who did
declared that the pandemic was over and
overall even though it was an h1n1 it
was moderately stood only moderately
severe and the public perception this is
the great difficulty that we're going to
have to live with for the future is that
in the Australian expressed it fairly
well the newspaper the pandemic that
never was I was one of the scientists
that made the predictions that it could
have the potential to be very severe
based on h1n1 1918 and it turned out not
to be correct so we are faced with
predicting uncertainties next one just
to for those that are not virologists
just to introduce influenza and a couple
of its properties that allows it to be
so variable it has a segmented genome of
8r
Eggman's and this allows it to reassert
its genome in one round of mating where
you have two different influenza viruses
you can have 256 different children from
one round of mating and and so this is
one of the strategies that the virus can
use and does use to generate many
different genotypes the other property
is it's an RNA virus and there's no
proofreading mechanisms so the errors
that are introduced during replication
stay there they're not corrected and and
some of my students compared the
replication of flu to one of the old GM
production lines after a weekend party
where the workers are just throwing the
bits in at random and every now and
again you get a successful one and in a
sense of what flu does it makes many
many many mistakes but then it'll come
up with the right combination of
nucleotides to be successful and these
are expressed mainly in the
hemagglutinin spike that attaches to you
respiratory tract and the neuraminidase
that releases the virus and in all of
the other genes as well next one
so I I want to go back to why did we say
that this pandemic of 2009 could be
severe it was really based on our
historical knowledge of h1n1 Spanish
influenza in 1918 World War one was
going on and it was America's secret
weapon the German generals maintained it
was not the tanks and the soldiers that
came from United States it was the fact
that United States used
biological warfare to finish World War
one and that is probably the case the
American dough boys took h1n1 from the
United States to France and in the
trenches were so close that it blew over
and really that was what finished World
War one between 50 and 100 million
people died next one
thus far as that could contrast' back
this virus did come from United States
the young soldiers were it showed up at
Fort Funston in Kansas and so why was it
called Spanish if it came from there
because both sides in the war didn't
want to acknowledge that the virus was
present and they'd been outbreaks in
Spain so they called it Spanish flu so
it wasn't British flu or American flu it
was Spanish flu next one and the the
doughboys that were put onto ships and
taking taken to Europe the USS Leviathan
when you read the history it was
absolute nightmare to travel on that
ship it was the ship from hell with nine
thousand young soldiers on board enroute
2000 were desperately ill ninety one
died and when it got to breast on the
8th of October there were 20 miles of
ambulances and carts taking the thick of
this ship and so the generals in United
States had decided that maybe this they
shouldn't send more troops because most
of them were dying in route
but President Wilson decided yes it had
to go on and so many young people died
enroute to get their next one and so
that that was what was going on at the
front but this virus spread rapidly all
over the world and for those that can't
see it this is a map of Alaska and was
the introduction of the virus to Alaska
the mail ship came in to Nome no ships
were allowed to land with flu on board
and so there was no apparent flu on
board they unloaded the letters gave
them to the letter carriers and the one
of the letter carriers set off with his
dog team towards Brevig mission he got
sick on the way but unfortunately the
dogs brought him in and then from the 15
to the 20th of November 72 of 80 people
of breathing died so that the virus had
spread that far
the children survived next one and so
jeffery taubenberger wanted to know why
was that virus so pathogenic and to try
to understand it he wanted to establish
the total sequence of the genome and had
got samples from the Armed Forces
Institute of Pathology and working
through them and hadn't finished the
sequence and he thought he wasn't going
to succeed and got a telephone call from
Joanne Holton to say did he want some
samples of 1918 tissue from Brevig
mission and Jeffery I understand almost
fell off the telephone with excitement
with the possibility of getting this
tissue and to cut a long story short
Jeffery established the total sequence
of the 1918 influenza virus but having
the total sequence he didn't know
surprise to all of us he really didn't
know anything looked at the sequence and
and so from the sequence itself you
couldn't decide why this virus was so
pathogenic next one so it was a case of
putting the virus back together again
and eventually with there was a lot of
toing and froing should it be done and
so on and eventually yes it was done
both the Centers for Disease Control and
co-worker did it in Canada at the bo4
facilities and the he used reverse
genetics to using the sequence
established by taubenberger to remake
the virus he remade 1918 as much
argument as whether it should be done
and what we needed to learn about it
then he put it into macaques put into
nine macaques and he put also put an h1
in one of the current time of 2001 into
macaques did limited replication
transient cytokine activation and very
mild 1918 was disastrous they macaques
had to be put down eventually extremely
high virus loads in the respiratory
tract in this cytokine activation
primary virus pneumonia and death but
they had to put them on his down so this
virus
truly did have in eight pathogenic
potential next one so where do they come
from
where do these viruses come from and in
1968 when I entered this field
it really wasn't established but to cut
the story short it's all sixteen
hemagglutinin nine-year m in a days
sometimes I carried by these small
shorebirds that migrate through Delaware
Bay
to Canada each year next one and sir
we've been following the influenza
viruses that might that come up with the
ruddy turn the stones and the red knots
these are the two principle ones and
this bird the ruddy Turnstone is the one
that really carries flu why we just
don't know why
and the when they come to Delaware Bay
I'll come to that in the moment the the
other group of birds that we've been
following since 76 are the Ducks that
migrate every year down to Central
America to overwinter the Canadian
waterfowl and in the duck and in the
ruddy Turnstone and the virus replicates
mainly in the intestine and ass fecal
oral transmitted next one so come come
to Delaware Bay this is the picture of
Delaware Bay mid May 16 17th of May the
horseshoe crabs come up out of the bay
and this were taken a number of years
ago unfortunately there's not as many
horseshoe crabs anymore lay their eggs
and that the birds enroute from the tip
end of South America come through and
put on 20 percent of their body weight
in two or three days from the horseshoe
crab eggs marvelous example of biology
and evolution that corresponds and so
here's my friend the ruddy Turnstone why
they are shedding about 20 up to 20
percent of these birds pooping out flu
why what makes them do it where did it
come from
we don't have the answers so as I've
pointed out to many of the young people
there are many many questions that we
still have unresolved
Delaware Bay is unique so these are the
figures for a couple of the years from
the virus picked up on the beach from
the poop other places in the world don't
have anything like as much they don't
have horseshoe crabs next one and Sarah
is summarizing that so far H 1 2 & 3 now
all of the subtypes occur in the wild
birds where it's benign in nature and
it's only after transferring to domestic
chickens 5 & 7 become very nasty viruses
and occasionally 5 7 & 9
transmitted to humans and we'll come
back to h5 in a little bit they haven't
succeeded in transmitting human to human
the pig is also infected so the biology
is the pig is certainly involved
somewhere there is a tendency to think
that only H 1 2 & 3 are going to cause
pandemics and Peter Polizzi and I go
back and forwards on this because Peter
thinks it's only those three but I keep
reminding him let's look at h7 here in
horses one of the most ancient of all
flu strains is h7 in 7 in horses I think
it actually has disappeared from the
horse but for many centuries
h7 was in horses and that's a mammal if
you have one so the possibility is can't
be ruled out next one the attitude
really established these principles
really who gives a damn
really it's irrelevant I mean it's
neither the agricultural people would
have support us public health people
give money for doing this kind of work
until next one until a child died in May
1997 and aged five and one from October
started spreading and then the recent
pandemic of h1n1 leaves no doubt where
these viruses come from and so we'll
deal with more about that shortly next
one so this is really the zua notic
transfer of from the wild aquatic birds
were probably through domestic ducks and
even quail to the pig and the pig seems
to be an essential piece of the story
next one but why doesn't occur more
often I mean there's millions of flu
viruses out there and there are plenty
of people in contact with working with
chickens and ducks and things and there
are so many changes to get an avian
virus from the avian properties to
mammalian there's many many changes the
temperature of the avian is 42 degrees
it's missing something happened this
should be over here malian and humans 37
site of replication and testin all
respiratory mode of spread fecal water
respiratory different receptors terminal
silac acids so when you take all of
these different properties means changes
many many changes are involved and we'll
come to the emergence of h1n1 the recent
one took nearly a hundred years to get
it right next one
so these are the pandemics that we know
about in the past century 1918 the one
we talked about there was so disastrous
in Europe and throughout the world
jeffery taubenberger maintained that it
all came from the aquatic bird reservoir
my colleagues that I work with
intensively in Hong Kong say no it is a
reassortant with some jeans for
transmissibility from humans and the
hemagglutinin and neuraminidase from the
duck reservoir and it usually goes
through the pink for this to occur for
the asian 57 three genes came from the
duck the hemagglutinin and neuraminidase
and pb-1 transmissibility from humans
and again it occurred in 68 with
reassortment the segmented genome allows
the virus to generate novel virus and
vast differences in in pathogenicity
between these next one so what's special
about the pink which viruses will
transmit to the ph1 in 1 1918 certainly
did
h1n1 1979 in italy a pure bird virus
spread to pigs in 1993 another h1n1 in
china spread to pigs
so there is something special about h1n1
and peas and again we don't know the
answer of what that is other viruses
also from avians h9 into and many
occasionally h5 n2 will spread to pigs
but they don't spread peak-to-peak and
each of the human viruses h1 h3 I don't
think a
to Winton to pigs that we know about
next one so turning to Europe what
happened in Europe with the influenza in
pigs sometime prior to 1979 one of the
avian viruses in presumably in the wild
ducks spread into peas and that became
pushed all of the other virus flu
viruses out of pigs and this became
dominant in Europe and it mated with
human viruses to give double reassortant
in peace in Europe next one then we go
to the United States in 1918 h1n1 spread
to pigs then that virus stayed in pigs
in the United States and was
antigenically completely stable it
didn't mix and mate it was what I call
monogamous until 1998 nearly a hundred
years it stayed in pigs didn't change
much then in 1998 something happens next
one the something is the gene segments
that came in from the avian species
presumably the PA in the PB to other
gene segments came from classical swine
and human to give what we call the
triple reassortant virus next one and so
recapitulate what I was saying 1918 to
1998 the h1n1 virus in the piggy stayed
extremely stable not reassortant
mixing it up and so the monogamous
period then from 1998 to 9 2009 these
the the virus in pigs or the triple
reassortant mated with everything in
sight they were
and they're still doing it the in United
States currently surveillance and pigs
are showing many different combinations
and in today's promed there is the human
h1n1 and h3n2 are mixing it up which
doesn't normally occur and so this is
this is something that is really going
to we going to have to watch for because
this tendency what makes the virus
recombinant Pro again more questions for
the future what makes this virus
recombinant prone when in the past it
was not recombinant Pro and the human
viruses h1 and h3 they each stayed
phylogenetic separate lineages this
incident in Canada that was described
this morning is really very worrying
next one so the the triple reassortant
in United States and the bird virus that
spread to pigs somewhere it got together
was it in Mexico the Mexicans would like
to say it wasn't where we think it was
but we're not sure did he humid it occur
somewhere else in a human bring it in we
don't know where it happened the best we
can say that occurred in Mexico next one
so 2009 h1n1 appears we need a vaccine
in a hurry and we'll come back to that
later next one so this between April and
November this virus spread remarkably
fast all over the world at least 6,000
deaths in
the six months not particularly high in
addition it also spread back to pigs
turkeys cats dogs ferrets
it has great transmissibility next one
and so this is where we got it wrong why
we got it wrong when we made
recommendations to the President on
should he take this pandemic 2009
seriously we think yes you shouldn't you
should make stockpiles get vaccines
ready as fast as possible when we look
at the difference between Spanish 1918
and 2009 antigenically structurally the
hemagglutinin of these is exactly the
same antigenically very very close but
when in time we find that the yield in
human airway cells 1918 produces 50
times as much the receptor binding both
alpha to 60 like ends but the 1918
combines with longer chains the thing
that is different are these pathogenic
markers PB to the lysine at 6:27 was not
present the PB 1 M 2 was not present the
PDC domain was not present and of course
we have antibiotics now to prevent the
secondary infections this is the this
this is why we got it wrong because we
based our recommendations on
antigenicity and structure next one
so one of the things that has been
lacking in influenza surveillance
there's a network through the World
Health Organization that studies human
in human influenza and there's quite a
lot of work done at the wild bird level
and in domestic poultry when this
outbreaks very little work done in pigs
and this the the place in the world
where Pig studies were done was in Hong
Kong might after the outbreak of h5n1
and Hong Kong
we put into place in Hong Kong from 1998
to the present time surveillance monthly
surveillance of a virus and serology and
that has allowed us to learn a great
deal about flu in pigs currently 50% of
the pig is coming into Hong Kong and
they come from all of a sudden all over
China so we can monitor really what's
happening pandemic h1n1 is everywhere
now h3n2 the old human one has gone and
the virus continues to throw off mate
reassortant different combinations so
it's still trying it on next one this is
in this week's nature my colleagues and
ourselves published on the what's
happening in Hong Kong based on the
viruses the original classical swine
virus peaked
some years ago and reduced and has been
replaced by the European avian virus the
triple reassortant was brought in with
pigs from United States and the pandemic
appeared
in 2009 so in Asia all of the players
are present and I keep asking my
colleagues are you sure that that's not
where it came from and they assure me no
it didn't that it came from Mexico next
one okay we're gonna switch from a
twenty and one to h5n1 next one so h5n1
emerged in 1996 and southern China is
now spread to over 60 countries in
Eurasia over 500 million poultry have
been destroyed and many poultry farmers
completely destroyed been 555 human
cases 324 deaths and so this is not
trivial if you get infected there was
trouble unfortunately it has established
multiple epicenters next one are going
to get back i I was involved with the
early studies in Hong Kong where was the
virus coming from after the first and
second child had died it was coming
directly out of the poultry markers and
this is an actual shot of the poultry
markets with the ducks and the chickens
and the quail and everything together in
these markets and so the the the live
markets were the breeding ground I look
upon the live bird markets as PCR
machines because every day you bring in
clean chickens and you put and you leave
the pheasants and other birds behind and
so just amplifies and they never in
1996-97 they weren't cleaning them out
next one
so this is one of one of the things the
reasons have happened in Hong Kong was
that Hong Kong built high-rise live
poultry markets instead of having
outside markets that you get in many
countries in Asia they built you know
high-rise markets and a note that they
actually the the kindergarten is right
next to the market so hmm next one and
this is when you work when we walked
into the first floor of the market what
did you find
chickens chickens everywhere next one
not only chickens but quail and pigeons
and pheasants underneath here if you
anyone can read Chinese
doesn't really say my Connie says that
science says be careful the floor is
whipped be careful the floor is slippery
and it's not because of water so much
because of so it's not surprising
children coming in here got infected
next one and so this is the the the
chicken was decided that they were
famous and and the paparazzi certainly
drove us crazy
days in Hong Kong but the all of the
poultry were slaughtered in Hong Kong
everything and the epic curve fell to
nothing no more human cases and for five
years
there was no h5n1 in Hong Kong but it
came back in from southern southern
China next one and 2004 it come came
back in and this time it got into wild
birds and Qinghai Lake and the wild
birds spreaded westward to India Africa
and and throughout much of that area of
the world next one oh no let's stay
there for a moment but note it has not
spread this way it has not spread to the
Americas or to Australia and I don't
understand why and it really hasn't USDA
and wildlife service's have sampled
hundreds of thousands of wild birds no
h5n1 and yet there is more than 6
million birds migrate backwards and
forwards including the Ducks why isn't
it moving we don't know we really don't
understand why it hasn't been brought in
that way and when we compare the
influenza viruses of the world they fall
into two major families the Americans
and the Eurasian is almost as though
there is a an imaginary line that they
the infected ones can't cross or
something we don't know why next one
so this is the current situation h5n1
still going on in Europe mainly in
eastern Asia India Bangladesh China and
in Egypt Indonesia is a constant worry
and so is Egypt next one since 1997 the
h5n1 has developed into 10 different
distinguishable planes rain the dominant
clades and where they are at the moment
played one the original one that came
from Hunan Province is still in Vietnam
and Cambodia the virus in Indonesia
played 2.1 and these are the dominant
viruses the in Egypt to point to the
worrying one is to point three point two
that virus seems to be in wild birds and
we are not sure is it being perpetuated
in the wild bird or not it's not fully
understood next one
so the continuing h5n1 threat in 2011 39
humans cases so far with 18 deaths the
percentage of deaths is dropping don't
think there's any doubt about that
there are now multiple at least interest
not just Southeast Asia Indonesia
continues to be an epicenter in Egypt is
the most worrying at the moment
reassortment this ability to transfer
genes one to the other h3n2 and h5n1
will reassert successfully and that some
have increased neural ins it's not been
found only in the laboratories have been
shown not in the field the secret so far
is that there's no consistent
human-to-human spread as compared with
a21 this doesn't know how to spread
thank God the worrying feature is this
clade h5n1 that may be in the migratory
waterfowl because Korea keeps getting
infected the poultry in Japan that keep
bringing the virus back in so long as
that virus is out there we stand the
risk of it learning to become a human
virus next one
so the problem is the duck the duck is
the big problem the duck is mainly
resistant to influenza some species of
duck the are sensitive that the pin tail
and the Mallard which are the dominant
virus in ducks in the world essentially
blow it off no disease and yet they the
virus replicates and they poop it out so
what's special about the duck next one
how's it I refer to the duck as the
truth of the Trojan horse in the Trojan
horse of flu because the farmers don't
want to spend money vaccinating ducks
because they don't show disease and if I
go and RIE have trouble with the duck
farmers because the virus is there and
they're spreading the virus around in
the city of problem for the chickens
next one sir resistance to influenza in
ducks is due to the fact that in part
due to the fact that the duck has the
rig-i the influence of sense
the chicken dozens somewhere in the
general in the evolution of the chicken
it lost ring I and sir you put the same
virus into the duck or the chicken the
duck looks perfectly healthy the chicken
is next pollen and so rig-i initiates
production of the interferon the beaten
pathway leads to the innate immunity to
in in the duck and the students in the
in Canada in transferred the rig-i from
duct cells into chicken cells and then
they can so the question that arises
should we now make the transgenic
chicken put rigor high into war chickens
for the future and when seriously
considering this on the other hand if we
do that I I'm not so sure that's a good
thing because then we'll have chickens
that behave like ducks that look healthy
poop the virus on us and surged more
likely if we do
which we've got to do something else's
way so the idea of transgenic chickens
for the big I we thought it'd be useful
but probably not next one so I I'm going
to bring this to a close very soon and
just goes through the lessons that we've
learned over the last couple of years
influenza pandemics are unpredictable in
respect to subtype in respect to
severity w-h-o got to spain to little
bits for not calling severity and might
have to agree that they they made all of
the right calls on h1n1 that they didn't
tell people it really wasn't very severe
and they should have done so and so they
have a scale for measuring pandemics it
has no sense instability so we have to
revise we have to revise the pandemics
and get a sense of severity
and they the thing that really blew us
all away was the emergence of an h1
independent pandemic while seasonal h1n1
was still circulating none of us and
that it was structurally and
antigenically identical with 1918 this
the reason the advisors like myself got
it wrong
China is very happy that the viruses
came from North America because for many
many years I first went into China in
1972 and we had the hypothesis that
China was the source of all pandemics of
flu Chinese were extremely gracious even
back to 1972 and disagreed with us but
they still listened and but I have to
say that currently they're happy that it
came from Mexico and not having fun next
one so innocent on severity the overall
was rather modest
but it was severe in young adults to a
70% of the cases we've heard two groups
that have was very severe in the obese
five times more likely to be
hospitalized very serious problem for
the
sure I don't think it's special for the
strain of blue a little bit more perhaps
pregnant women that make up 1% of the
population they made up 5% of the death
so that's all behind the screen the
virus replicated deep in the lungs
because that's where the health birth to
three receptors are found in humans and
this virus still has some free delivery
for the next one so the lessons on
evolution and surveillance the studies
in Hong Kong from the field studies
showed that this virus had been out
there in peace between 9 and 17 years
it's been out there that length of time
we hadn't picked it out very naughty
offers we didn't do surveillance and
things so one of the clear messages
surveillance and healthy things has to
be done but I do bump heads a little bit
with the pig board in the United States
who really don't want us messing with
their healthy penis and finding viruses
in that we try to explain to them - no
problem for Danny we just have to
educate people that these viruses really
are there and by studying them we
we'll be ahead of the game for making
vaccines next one the lessons on
antivirals and vaccines I don't have
time keep you here all night about the
value of 19 urine and AIDS drugs they
were extremely valuable unfortunately we
only have one drug when you're a minute
as drugs the other drug amantadine dry
mentally the viruses resistant to it the
neuraminidase that came in from Europe
the viruses resistant to it and so it's
only a matter of time before we lose
this drug vaccines it takes too long to
make them and so we have to use our new
technologies and we talk before the
young people that there is an exciting
possibility of vaccines cross-reactive
determines between one of the subtypes
which has been identified what a trial
antibodies made and the verifications
serve is a slight possibility but
possibly ended I see there are problems
with word problems with sharing viruses
in developing countries and that's been
pretty much worked out next one so
looking to future I think one of the one
of the things that we do know we can
improve biosecurity and keep the wild
birds with wild birds live and the
domestic birds where they live and we
have to raise we really do have to raise
domestic poultry enclosed houses if we
have the opening power system we can
continue to have very big problems we
have to establish swine
the level of the burden of flu and swine
and the model of surveillance and
figures in Hong Kong is is a perfect
model to reuse and hopefully the
genomics of influenza virus reservoir
species will allow us to make
predictions in the future yes that based
on the genome the stage next one now
this really sums up where we spend at
the moment the riders of the Apocalypse
that guy gives me the creeps
but h5n1 is out there so obvious is out
there it has the potential of picking up
transmissibility from somewhere just
because it hasn't happened in 15 years
doesn't mean the state didn't want it
this ability of h1n1 to Rhea sort now
and we started to see it in humans
so we do have to keep making mix one
couple
a French philosopher that's this thing
so I really wanted to just say thank you
to all the people who work with me and I
knowledge them and my it's coming
quickly we could do it ah right there
okay next one and so this is one might
pit peed at the moment in the United
States one of the things to do is to
have raise your own chickens in your
backyard and in Egypt they've spent lots
of money getting the chickens out of the
backyard the United States that
introducing the needs of the backyards
so maybe it's not such a brilliant idea
to heaven serve a wild chicken I think
we're really going to if we're going to
raise vast numbers of chickens and peas
I'm afraid they have to be done in those
facilities to keep them away from the
one of life otherwise they become
amplifiers sooner or later what hasn't
happened so far h5n1 hasn't gotten
better people's if it does
next one I just want to thank the
National Institutes of Health's for
supporting the studies the many young
people Richard webby has taken over the
group in Memphis now Ivonne and Malik
Peiris and Hong Kong in particular Kevin
Smith in Duke in Singapore who does the
genomic analysis and studies and Egypt
Canada Korea thank you for that
fascinating and illuminating talk is as
always gives us a great deal I think to
think about and even to worry about the
1918 influenza was the worst natural
disaster in history and we obviously are
all concerned about the reoccurrence of
something like that
and obviously this is a prime subject
for prediction understanding and and
thank you for that illuminating talk
that I think gives us a great deal to
think about but also all the work that
you've done to illuminate and really
deepen our understanding and and provide
the understanding of where these viruses
are coming from the floor is open for
pieces that came from walkers to
backyard for fevers there is a risk in
the big commercial farms but I think in
the United States there's policies put
in place and the bigger poultry farms
are learning more and more that they
have to be operated as closed and and so
that the the little birds the what has
to be treated the little birds can't fly
in and out and so as much as I like to
think about green raising of eggs and
poultry I'm sorry it's not going to work
for flu its we're going to leave
ourselves open for the generation of at
least this emerging disease by having
open big we can't have big and open it
is just just not on small and openness
it depends on how frequent the small
occurs it's I think the the reason for
the absence of highly pathogenic
influenza in the world in the past is
that they just burned itself out and
there wasn't enough contact to spread it
and so it depends on the density of
small what do you think the sort of
trend towards large industrialized pork
farmers such as what's found in Mexico
around seem to emerge do you think that
this is going to have an impact on it
will if it's not a closed system indeed
it's some of the I I have a couple of
slides that I sometimes use on the the
production combined production in Iowa a
few years ago where they were raising
turkeys in one barn and pigs in the
other on the same big production farms I
think that stopped now but that was
happening and they weren't fully closed
systems if you do that you're asking for
trouble
and again when we raise huge numbers of
pigs concentrated pigs it's going to
have to be controlled so controlled
access for humans vaccinate the people
that are working in there as well
thank you very much for coming to speak
with us I know the situation in Egypt is
a concern is there any evidence about
how the virus smuggled poultry or
through wild birds is there is can can
you follow scientists follow the virus
closely enough to know how it arrives
there as far as we can tell based on the
genomics of the virus its clade two
point one point two and this is the one
that came through Quinn high Lake that
the the virus got into the wild birds
and the wild birds spread it to the I
don't the other hypothesis is it spread
along the rail route roads in Russia and
was carried and smuggled but it occurred
in too many different places with the
same genomic virus occurred so many
different places that the wild birds are
playing a role I sure want something
with you that I don't normally talk
about the I don't know how many people
realize that the duck preens itself it
has a preening land that it spreads oil
all over its feathers and we are looking
into the possibility that the preening
oil can carry virus on the outside and
sir
we're finding that preening oil will
concentrate flu and can these conducts
carry flu not in the intestinal tract
but on the preening on their feathers
with preening oil
that's something we have to look at
thank you
so just returning to the h1n1 virus for
a second I was honoring since you said
that their viral markers were so
different if you could shed some light
on why the excess mortality trends in
terms of age group distributions were so
similar for example in the 2009 pandemic
we had around 8,000 deaths in middle age
group with significantly less like four
times less in the outside age groups and
we saw something similar my hearing is a
down a little bit so they shout at me a
little more sure uh so just returning to
h1n1 first yes right um you said that
their viral markers were very different
but I was wondering if you could explain
or perhaps shed some light on the
question of why the distributions of
mortality and infection in terms of age
groups were so similar so for example in
2009 we had around 8,000 deaths in the
middle age group but like less than 2000
on the outside and we saw something
similar in the age spectrum during 1918
as well so I I don't know that I've got
an answer for you I really I think you
you may have thought of it more than I
you know it's an interesting question
but you know much is made in 1918 of the
W shaped curve with that coming up in
the middle and you can in fact just look
at things like crude death rates or P&I
pneumoniae influenza death rates to see
that it's it's so striking and of course
that's not usually the case but I don't
know how much analysis has actually been
done of those epidemic curves in 2009 I
I don't know at the moment so that's
something that I'm sure is going to be
done
and I think one other sort of an
interesting question there is is why
pregnant women and why are pregnant
women if it's greater risk and is this
unique to 2009 it's at the moment it
seems to be somewhat unique to 2009 they
I don't have the answers it's to do I
believe it to do with the hormonal
responses and the innate responses and
some form of over-production of one or
other of the cytokines and probably in
that area talked about the debate that
you had with Peter for lazy about the
question of whether you made the point
that he didn't take into account age 7
and I have to say I wasn't able to
follow you at that point in the long
history of 8 7 among horses so could you
just expand on that a bit and in terms
of what did she tell us her so yeah so
which of the 16 subtypes have caused
diseases in mammals h1 h2 and h3 humans
and also in pigs and the only other
virus that is really step established a
long term lineage is the h7 in horses
equine one in horses has been in horses
for a very very long time so it is says
to me that the mammal the horse can
support the the transmission of h1n1 and
so we can't rule out the fact that an h5
or an h7 could be established
in a mammalian host Peter thinks that
there is something about the other
subtypes that precludes them from
getting transmissibility in humans he
doesn't know any more than I do us why
but but it based historically if you
look at the past century and back into
ancient history it's only h1 h2 h3 the
only other example is h7 and horses no
questions annoying one is about studies
that have been done differentiating the
American ducks from the non American
ducks and and I assume that they're
fairly elaborate studies being worked on
on innate in bodies of some sort or
another way that the environment so that
one that the difference between there
there are no difference between American
ducks and European and Chinese ducks
there really is no difference in in the
ability to in the asian ducks are just
as resistant as american down so the the
the reason why the virus is not coming
h5n1 is not coming to the americas we
don't know we just do not know why h5n1
has come across we believe the duck
spread it to Egypt and Africa why
doesn't it come the other way
in other words it's not thought that
there's some
sort of very subtle reaction of the
immune system operating in the American
dollar no okay my other question is
rather wild but anyway with all the
discussions about antibiotics in the
vulpine world and the like has any of
that through water transfer or anything
like that had anything to do with these
changes in the past decade in in all of
these flus and the increased activity I
mean is there any kind of correlation at
all not with antibiotics in in in with
influenza because the antibiotics don't
I don't have any effect on but you raise
and actually a very interesting issue
along the same lines the antiviral drug
Tamiflu they the Tamiflu is is excreted
through the kidneys into the water
supply and is actually being picked up
in the water supply and in the rivers in
Japan so it is not being destroyed and
the question is are we going to see
Tamiflu resistant viruses appearing
amongst the wild birds so follows on
from what you were saying one of the
good things about Tamiflu is its
stability so we don't have to renew the
stockpiles that haven't been used but on
the other hand there's this downside
that it can get into the water supply
and be around for some time how do you
think the 1918 virus got to the United
States how did you get to the United
States well it's supposed to originated
in United States it
presumably it until it occurred through
the same mechanism as the Asian and Hong
Kong of reassortment it just got its
genomes in a row it's and there are so
many possible combinations that it just
got it ducks in a row if you like so so
in that case some pandemics mean most of
the pandemics we've people have looked
at historically have come from Asia
usually China ostensibly but there are
exceptions that and does that mean if we
are looking for the source of the next
pandemic we have to be geographically
open-minded as well as viral aaja Clee
open-minded i think we have to be
open-minded but continue to look in Asia
very one you spoke to some of the
problems with the vaccinations for birds
for h5n1 would is this something that
you think should be pursued still
realizing that it has built up potential
immunity within some of the flocks that
you spoke to in Vietnam and other places
is this something that we should be
aiming to do whether to continue
vaccinating or stop vaccinating them
twice or three times they're supposed to
is this something that we should
realizing that its leading to potential
immunity within the ducts and as you
conserving you're not gonna do the the
the the ultimate solution of course is
to stamp it out and so we have to think
in terms of trying to get it stamped out
and I with with countries like Indonesia
and Vietnam with big duck populations
and the virus entrenched in the duck
populations very hard to see how to do
it without a massive input of expertise
and probably funding from through FAO
and Hawaii to really help them get it
out they can't do it alone
i I just don't think it can be done
different place
I I think what one of the the lessons to
me about influenza the the h5 viruses is
that the there is cross clade protection
in the poultry vaccines poultry vaccines
made with mineral oil adjuvant one of
the most potent edge events it was used
in humans many many years ago it's a
superb edge event but it causes a
necrotic poss-eye
and you can't use it of course but you
can in a chicken put it under the skin
then and it works so you the the
available information is that there is
cross clade protection between all the
variants providing you used enough
antigen and one of one of the
difficulties with the poultry vaccines
is they're not standardized for content
some of the vaccines are good and some
of them are not so good in terms of
antigen content but the the vaccines
they have the best edge of n't that we
can't use in humans are there any
further questions
the swine flu vaccine 76 but but that's
the official shelf-life it's less than
one year yes indeed so we haven't done
the science and of course industry is
interested in having a new vaccine next
year to get rid of that last log so the
shelf-life could be extended but the in
reality in humans the virus is changing
sufficiently so you most years you need
to make a new vaccine anyway this year
we didn't have to make a change all of
the strains say the exactly the same the
first time for twenty years I would bet
bet bet but the ethics committees would
not agree with me that ethically you
can't do that I mean it's the shelf-life
is one year or whatever nine months and
ethically you can't do it wasn't there
also a lot of discussion at the time
about how much cross reactivity there
was between the 1976 or the antibodies
raised by the 76 versus earlier
immunizations for h1n1 complicates the I
don't know the bottom line on those
there has been some unusual findings in
Australia and in Canada of reactivity
and I think this is associated with high
levels of newer than today's in the
vaccine anyone else any further
questions thank you all very much for
your attendance and your very
interesting questions please join me in
thanking our